the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
if i wanted you to remember three
equations really commit them to memory
that allow you to essentially do
everything that we've done they'd be the
following three the first would
essentially be Newton's second law we
use that all the time and in vector form
summation of the external forces on a
rigid body must be equal to the time
rate of change of the linear momentum of
the rigid body and that we know is equal
to its mass times the acceleration of
its center of mass with respect to an
inertial frame and this the slash o
means with respect to an inertial frame
that's Newton's second law and of course
we use it all the time
now oiler improved added to what Newton
worked out for us and let me actually
just point out over here so P with
respect to O then is M velocity of G
with respect to the inertial frame
vector vector vector okay what a lot on
us was that the summation of the torques
about a point a is a time rate of change
of the angular momentum with respect to
that point plus the velocity of the
point cross p with respect o so that's
our general equation for angular
momentum
our four torques and remember H with
respect to a is the cross product of our
I will write this guy
so we define angular momentum at just a
cross product of the distance from the
point that we're at to the ended right
this right this is a with respect to G
cross P oh so that's our general
definition of angular momentum and
finally the third equation is the one
that I showed you last time but you does
appear in the book but not until you get
into chapter 21 and that is that you can
write H with respect to a as H with
respect to G Plus RG a cross P with
respect oh it's something along here I
Matt whatever done wrong with my brain
because I don't do it I don't think
about think about this this is the yeah
to summation there we go in general this
is a summation and it is the location of
all the little particles I with respect
to a cross the linear momentum of each
particle em I the I with respect to O
and we add all that up we get the anger
it's a definition of angular momentum
and we generally for rigid bodies then
reduce that to saying that it's a mass
moment of inertia matrix computed with
respect to a times Omega X Omega Y Omega
Z that's how we generally express this
but the third equation I want to come to
is this one
yeah this is iris with recta a let's
just let's just do this so I've just
slipped a bit this morning okay I'm
thinking too much about where I'm going
here this equation I introduced last
time the book doesn't make a big deal
about this at all but it's really it's a
fundamental equation we proved from
scratch very simply last time and this
this equation allows you to solve lots
of problems without even for example
knowing the parallel axis theorem it'll
just get you through it even without
knowing things like that so with these
three equations you do all the problems
that we've done and I'm going to do two
or three examples this morning just kind
of in including coming back to a
discussion of the parallel axis theorem
okay so these three are the ones you I
recommend that you remember okay because
everything else will flow from we know
like we have special cases so when a is
at one a is at G right then the the
velocity or when the yeah when a is a G
then this just this just reduces to H
with respect to G when there's no valano
when a doesn't move this term goes away
those are all special cases which you
can just substitute in the numbers and
discover for yourself if you don't
remember those but these are the three
equations you want to have in your kit
to use
so last time I kind of classified
problems in four different classes
depending on these simplifications right
and the class for problem was the more
general case and that's when the point a
can is allowed to move or para is
allowed to move in general and that last
equation we had there came was very can
be very handy in those cases and I
mentioned a problem last time but I
didn't work it out and that's simply
this problem where you've got a block
maybe a box on a cart and you want to
and you're accelerating the cart at what
point will block tip over so this one
I've put a nail right here so the block
can't slide but it will tip about this
point so if I accelerate it slowly
nothing happens if I accelerate it fast
enough it tips around that point so
that's the key points half that work so
that's the key bit what's the greatest
acceleration that I can have so that
this block will just not quite tip
that's the problem if you didn't have
the nail there there's also the
possibility that will slip without
tipping over so that's another problem
we will address it another another
moment ok let's do this problem quickly
so this is our problem and I've got a
handle here and I'm pushing on it with a
force got a couple of wheels this is M 1
this is M 2 and I'll have a neural frame
here X Y so the question is what's the
maximum force that I can apply such that
the block won't tip over
and I've got a little nub there so this
thing can't slide okay and this is my
point a because that's the point I
expect it to rotate around the XY and Z
is coming out of the board
okay so Newton's second so we apply it
first from Newton's second law we say to
some of the forces in this case on the
system by the system I mean m1 and m2 we
want to remember that you can collect
things together at times so some of the
forces on the system in this case is
then m1 plus m2 and it's the
acceleration of that point and in this
case we are just going to do in the
x-direction because we know that's the
only one where there's any action so the
sum of the forces in the x-direction is
the total mass of the system times the
acceleration in the x-direction so the x
double-dot we're looking for is f over
m1 plus m2
so this is trying to find out what the
maximum value for this is
now next we can apply the torque
equation because that's the key one and
that's some of the torques now it's just
on the box at with respect to point a
and we can say looking at that we need a
Freebody diagram now of our box you got
two m1g down and you might have a normal
force upwards generally but now we want
to think about where is the where the
force is going to be acting on the box
when it's just at this point that we
that it's just a barely about it just
barely starts to tip so we're
hypothesizing that here at a there'll be
some upward force right and it's going
to take care of the static equilibrium
but it's also you could enter into our
moment calculation if we weren't clever
with respect to where we calculate this
point okay so the sum of the torques
about this point we don't have to bring
this one into it we do have to consider
this one so the are here cross that
force we get a moment mg and I need some
dimensions on my box we'll call it B and
a height H
so the moment arm this axon is B over 2
and it's in the minus Z direction so I
get a minus m1g B over 2 okay hat
those are my external torques on the box
because the normal force supporting it
on the floor is acting at a now and
that's must this must be from our second
formula D H with respect to a DT plus
the velocity of a with respect to O
cross p with respect o and P with
respect o was m1 V G with respect to O
right so we need to know what is
velocity of a with respect to O well
we're only allowing motions in this
direction we have and this has to be
evaluated in the inertial frame so we
have a coordinate X here so it's going
to be some X dot and I'll give you a
capital I hat just remind you where
that's in the inertial frame what is the
velocity of G with respect to O
yeah you know in this condition we're
saying we want the block not to quite
tip over that means it's moving with the
car to exactly the same velocity so it's
the same it's also equal to a with
respect to O but if that's the case
what's the cross product between
velocity they expect o and G with
respect their o so that one goes to zero
after because of this okay okay so that
leaves us with we don't have to deal
with these terms but we do need to
compute H with respect to a and now I'm
going to use this formulation because it
makes this problems
easy to do I don't have to deal with
parallel axes or any of that so I'm
going to use my third equation and it
says that this is H with respect to G
plus our G with respect to a cross P
with respect to O so I'm going to now
you work at me so I notice I chose this
problem kind of on purpose today because
I started saying here's three really
important equations we use all three to
do this problem okay so now we're
exercising the third
to my block here since we're dealing
with angular momentum rigid bodies I now
have to think in terms of a coordinate
system attached to the block and I'll
formulate it so it's lined up the same
way so this is a x1 I'll call it y1 and
z1 but x1 and big X these are in the
same direction and so Z and Z 1 and
capital e and that means that my I hats
are the same as the unit vectors
associated with my coordinate system
attached to the body remember this is
this body sick body fixed coordinate
system and allows us to compute moments
of inertia and I'm going to have this
located at G ok
so the only rotation we're allowing in
this problem this is this is basically a
2d planar motion problem it could
conceivably have X&Y translations and a
z rotation constrained in the Y so it
has possible rotation and translation so
the only Z only Omega we're considering
is this Omega Z and so let's we'll
proceed to use it to compute H so we'll
use this formula so H with respect to G
is just I'm doing a couple of these
things sort of carefully just remind you
of where these things all come from this
is i with respect to G and in this case
zero zero Omega Z and we come out of
this then the only this is a are these
principal axes so if they are this is
diagonal right so I've located these
through G you know taken into
consideration the symmetries I know
because the symmetry these are principal
axes therefore this is a diagonal mass
moment of inertia matrix so when I
calculate to do out the multiplication I
get I ZZ with respect to G Omega Z K hat
that's the contract only one component
one vector component of H that comes out
of that and that's H Z is that if I ZZ g
omega z k hat there are two other
possible components of H but they're
both zero there's no other Rho K there
is no other no angular momentum in the X
or Y directions okay
our GA in this problem is from here this
is point a to there so our G with
respect to a is B over 2i plus h over to
K it's the location of just the position
of G with respect to a B over 2 over H
over 2 up ok so in order to complete my
calculation of H of a I need to get the
second piece so the RG a cross B OH
so our GA is my B over 2i plus h over 2k
cross and then my egg my linear momentum
is M 1 X 1 dot in the I hat direction
and either be Capital high or lowercase
either the same right so this is my
second term the RG cross B I cross I
these two this pair gives you nothing so
it's K cross I as a J and so you get i
ZZ respect to G Omega Z and then a K
term from here M 1 H over 2 X dot and
it's also in the K and that's my total
angular momentum now with respect to a
and I think this is a cake you're right
wait a second k cross I should give me a
J right
yeah K cross I gives me a positive J
right this is this is it okay good catch
all right so what happens now now we get
J cross I gives you a - okay
now that should be okay and let's see if
that agrees with what I wrote here yes
they did write on the paper just
couldn't put it right on the board and
all okay
so now the sum of the torques with
respect to a we've already figured out
that it's minus m1g B over two K hat
must be equal to the time rate of change
of from our second equation dhdt and
we've already figured out that the
second term it goes away so it's just
then time rate of change of that
expression well I think we could
probably do it straight away so the time
ready to change the derivative of this
you're going to make a Z dot you get an
X double dot the K doesn't rotate so
there's nothing that comes from that you
take that time derivative you get AI Z Z
with respect to G Omega Z dot minus m1 H
over 2 X double dot and these are still
all in the K direction and that's a
that's an equation that it's only has K
hat terms on the left-hand side K on the
right so this is just one comp potential
component of the torque and so we can
drop the case at this point and we now
have an expression for the external
torques in terms of the accelerations of
the system this is essentially theta
double dot of the tips and that's the
linear acceleration but now then the key
to the problem is we're trying to find
out when just at the point it might tip
it doesn't so what's a mega dot magazine
so what we're looking for we let Omega Z
dot or require that to be zero this
makes this even simpler and you find out
then that m1g B over two equals m1 H
over to X double dot ad minus signs on
both sides so I've gotten rid of them
and then ones go away
and I can solve for H for X double dot
that's going to be G B over H okay and
we started off saying what's the maximum
force so this is now x max acceleration
maximum and the force maximum is just
equal to m1 plus m2 X dot X or and let's
see if that makes sense
if B and H were equal sort of a
common-sense argument here V and H were
equal that tells you that you could
accelerate this at 1g just one G and
that makes sense the mg here is putting
a restoring moment down of the mg B over
two and the acceleration of this is
putting a an overturning moment on it in
the other direction that would be M G H
over to innovation H and B are the same
that then it would be exactly 1g now so
that's the answer the problem if you'd
wanted to live dangerously from the
beginning you could have done this with
a fictitious force I just mentioned in
passing I'm not recommending that you
generally go there this was a very
straightforward way of doing it we just
started with these three laws and we
just worked our way through the problem
and just and all the way to the end and
it fell out if you did want to live
dangerously though you could say that
when you accelerate this you can think
of there being a fictitious force that
is equal to minus the mass of this
object times the acceleration on the
center gravity a force that is pulling
it in the other direction so you could
think of there being a force m1 x
double-dot
opposite to the direction of
acceleration this is minus the mass
times acceleration is the fictitious
force
here's your point a here's the graph
here's gravity m1 G this is the distance
B over 2 this is the height H over 2 and
you could say just at that moment of
balance the sum of those two moments
should be 0 to sum of the external
torques and you would end up with a m1 X
double dot H over 2 minus m1 G B over 2
and you come up with the same answer but
for most of us that's a that takes a
real leap of faith to do that then make
convince yourself that you're right
right you got to know a lot of dynamics
and remember all the parts and pieces to
be able to just go there but if you do
it just carefully those three equations
it'll all work out yeah
because as long as the conditions
satisfied that doesn't tip over
what's the rotation rate of this block
Sara
so we're not we're not solving for
dynamics in this problem of the thing
tipping it isn't rolling on us we're
coming just up to the point that it tips
and said we're not going any farther so
we just require the two moments the one
essentially caused by the acceleration
this fictitious force it's got to be
just in equilibrium with the restoring
moment provided by mg that's essentially
the problem we've worked but we've done
it really carefully just using these
three laws and the real problem though
if you didn't have the nail here is if
you know what you need to test your
solution could you ever actually reach
that rate of acceleration before the
things start sliding on you and you know
maybe not this thing slides before it
tips okay taking the cat m2 so the
angular momentum was all calculated with
respect to the bridgid body m1 right
the only reason m2 entered into it is
the this is the way things happen you
know in real life it's just a real
problem it's a box on a cart and you're
going to tip over and you're pushing on
it how hard can I push to do that
problem you just have to consider these
to begin with so that you realize that
oh the acceleration involves both of
these masses but the angular momentum
part of the problem involves only the
Box this tipping so there's you know but
problems even as simple as this one
looks has their little complications and
you've got to work you've got to work
through them so just so we had to treat
the body is a two-body system to start
with and then look at angular momentum
for just the box
yes absolutely
mm-hmm does it create a moment no and
that's cool and that's why we can don't
have to consider it I could have written
I could have put it in there and
probably should have if I'd done a free
body diagram here you could still say
that there is a reaction force upwards
here I'll call it ry and another one
this direction I'll call our X and when
computing moments about this point
neither of them entered into the problem
and that's why we like to do our
calculations for angular momentum with
respect to points around which the body
rotates because that allows us to not
have to solve for those unknown forces
that pop up there so yeah indeed their
forces there okay
got it figured out so we've you we've
talked a little tiny bit about parallel
axis theorem and so this I'm going to
consider this a slender rod I can spin
it about one of its principal axes and
calculate its angular momentum or
whatever I need and if I move it over to
an axis that's I just move it over by a
little bit let's say this is the chord
this is the x-axis here in my body this
is the Z so it's right Omega Z and I've
moved my axe at my point around which
I'm rotating over by a small amount a
that's this distance between these two
holes and by parallel axis theorem we
could say well now there's a mass moment
of inertia with respect to a which is
the mass moment of inertia with respect
to G which is M L squared over 12 if
this is the length plus the mass times
its distance squared we know how to do
that so but now what happens if I take
this this stick my slender rod
and here's my original X Y C and I want
to move it my point a my stick now I'm
going to move it over by an amount a and
up by an amount C so that it's now up
here with respect to this point so
that's this stick has been like this and
now I'm in it been rotated about that
that's a simple case now I want to
rotate it about this axis when it's
moved over to like that okay so not only
have I moved it so here's the original
problem like this but now I move it up
and over maybe I'll do it there
and now I spent it talking interested in
angular momentum about this point first
so now it's dynamically unbalanced for
sure this thing is trying to wobble and
it's been pushed up and over so is there
a way to get do we solve that problem
how do we compute the torques for this
problem well we can try to go at it with
parallel axis to start with but you
don't know how to do that in general for
this problem so what do we go to we go
back to those three equations and just
start there and it'll all fall out I'm
going to do this kind of briefly for
this problem so I want to compute H with
respect to a H with respect to G plus
our G with respect to a cross P and now
this is our G a is this vector right
here that position vector okay
and the only rotation is omega Z this is
our z axis so I can write this as Y Z Z
with respect to G 0 0 Omega Z plus my RG
a cross Pio and that in this problem
let's get the vector right this time
it's a in the I Direction plus C in the
K Direction cross now we need to know
what's P with respect to O but that's
just the velocity of this of the center
of mass which is now here the velocity
is omega cross R so when you do that we
had done that problem lots of times it's
this distance
it's the perpendicular distance cross K
you're got to be going into the board if
it's spinning like this we know the
answers got to come out plus J and it's
our it's a Omega Z in the J direction
cross M ay Omega Z but it is in the J
hat direction that's your linear
momentum and we're Krotz this is our GA
cross with the linear momentum this here
is M velocity of G here with respect oh
that's this term so we carry out this
calculation and we get and I need a J
okay
so I cross J gives me a k so I'll get 2
and this this is a diagonal matrix
because we began with a set of principal
axes for
stick so this term is AI Z Z with
respect to G I shouldn't have written Z
Z here just by with respect to Z we
multiply this out we get pick up just
this term Omega Z K hat plus I cross J
is K so that's M a squared Omega Z K and
K cross J is minus I minus M ay C Omega
Z in the I hat direction so this is my
angular momentum and reminding you know
it is a vector this has got components
in the K and the I directions
I rewritten it here this also could be
written this is H with respect to a is i
with respect to a times the rotation
vector if we had just set out with this
problem said we're going if we know the
mass moment inertia matrix computed with
respect to this point and multiplied it
by our our rotation rate vector we would
have gotten stood have gotten the same
answer so we didn't do that we just
worked it out using the straight form
just this formula but we've essentially
discovered the answer this is the
rotation around K this is the term this
is the I Z Z term with respect to a and
it really should looks like the familiar
parallel axis piece it's the amount that
you moved this axis over and your mount
you access your spinning around you
moved it over a and you know the
parallel axis theorem just says add MA
squared and you've got the answer but we
also moved it up and give us another
term what do you suppose that term is so
this is I Z Z with respect to a this
term by parallel axis theorem you're
familiar with it this one is I and this
is X Z with respect in the a coordinate
system okay this is we've created we've
made this thing unbalanced the angular
momentum vector no longer points in the
same direction as the rotation it has a
K component and an I component and sure
enough when I spin that thing like that
I feel that additional torque out to out
on the around my hand down here where
I'm holding it this thing is going kind
of pull it back and forth so we have
centrally just shown we've just arrived
at the parallel at a more complicated
parallel axis theorem by just using this
basic form oh so Williams in the
dynamics that second handout from
Williams has actually given us a general
formulation for parallel axis theorem so
this is just handy to know I'll just
give it to you and if you have problems
have a problem someday we're just like
to go directly to this statement so now
I'm just going to say in general we
could have moved over by a up by C and
actually into the board by another by B
so X I'm moving a why I'm moving B Z M
moving C okay so you could have all
those possible moves of the new point
about which you're rotating yes you are
rotating about point a the let me think
she died trying to think of a good way
to when you started this problem we're
spinning about the middle about G okay
and we can calculate angle angular
momentum of this object with respect to
GE and learn some things right but now
we've built a different device this is
just this is an object now that is in
fact spinning you know maybe if you know
let's imagine it's a fan blade and
you've broken one bite off now if the
motor is here the proper fan blade would
have you know blades on both sides so
it's nice and balanced the shaft has
some length that it sticks out and now
you break off one of the blades and so
you've got to you have assistants doing
this but this is going to put a lot of
unusual loads on this point down here so
it's but it's it is rotating at the same
rotation rate about this point but it is
now a system whose center of mass is
over here and it's up it's not only its
above this point and it's out from this
point the center of mass and now you
compute the angular momentum with this
point and take its time derivative you
will find all the torques required to
make this happen little louder
movement that you've moved the
center-of-mass away from this axis of
rotation and you've moved it so you've
moved it up and over
so let's actually let's the thing about
that for a minute this is our beginning
point right we're at G if I just move it
up
does it cause any problems it's still
balanced and you'll find out that
nothing's nothing's happened in this
problem H with respect to a is the same
as it was before all right
but now you move it up and over to
starts cause of complications yeah so I
like directions but you have an
ionization and ecstasy German you're
multiplying by a vector with an Omega
okay so the there's an I haven't gone
into this and I'm not going to wonder
this the I matrix is a thing called a
tensor and so this is just this is a
convention that you can make it a very
mathematical list and assigned unit
vectors to each of these terms inside
but I haven't done that but the
convention here is that this the H the
angular momentum is a vector it consists
of three components it has three
potential vector components H X in the
eye
H Y in the J and H Z in the K directions
and we in a compact form say we can
express that by multiplying its mass
moment of inertia matrix with respect to
a times the vector that is its rotation
now I only have one component of this
Omega but it is in the K direction and
the when you multiple when you take this
vector and multiply it by the top row
that gives you everything that's AI you
multiply this vector times the second
row it gives you everything is in the J
direction and the result is part of H Y
in the J direction you take this vector
and you multiply it by the third row it
gives you the Z directed components okay
so this one because this one when we
multiply this out I didn't what's in
this matrix is this matrix diagonal no
way and that's because that's we move it
we've gone done something strange here
it's not diagonal and when you multiply
this times this top row there's a term
here which is not zero shouldn't write
zero I make an X here this times this
gives you an Omega Z times that in the I
hat direction
okay this term comes from there being
something there okay and I'm just going
to give you a generalization that you
can go back and read the Williams
handout which he says if you want to
know you want to rotate about some fixed
point a then you can say that this
matrix is equal to the one with respect
to G which is in our case is diagonal
the original one that we had is doesn't
have to be but no way if you pick
principal axes this will be diagonal
plus em B squared plus C squared minus a
B minus AC it's symmetric this is a
squared plus C squared and so for
rotating a system if you know its mass
moment of inertia matrix with respect to
G the rest amount perhaps principal axes
and you want to rotate it about any
other point where you've moved it by an
a by a B by a C this is essentially the
general parallel axis theorem again you
can just plug it in and use that and you
can see what would happen in this case
if you multiplied you add these two
together they add term by term this goes
into the upper this point this one adds
to this okay so in this problem in our
particular problem this becomes you have
an I xx I YY eyes easy with respect to G
terms its diagonal to start with and
then we don't have a in our problem that
we did there we didn't have a B we did
have no B terms so the B terms are all 0
but you do end up with a minus AC term
over here and if you multiply this by 0
0 Omega Z see what happens you get minus
AC in the I direction and you need an M
here
and you come down here you get the eyes
ECG of omega Z in the K direction that's
those two terms here they are yeah hope
it on e 2 plus a squared yeah so
normally if you just take a stick and
you have an axe
move that parallel to the end you
wouldn't go yeah so if you just move it
so that I'm glad you asked the question
since normally that's the the types of
problems in which we usually use the
parallel axis theorem is you've been
spinning it around one axis everything
the principal axis everything's fine
and you want to just move that move it
over so we do that with when we do
pendulum problems here's the thing
around the center and we just want to
know what's how does this thing behave
when we move it up here it becomes a
pendulum and we would like to compute
the angular momentum around this point
we say oh we've moved at a distance D
the new mass moment of inertia in the Z
Direction is the original plus MD
squared right well that's the so when
you only make one move well you only
have an a a B or a C you never get any
of the off-diagonal terms because
they're products see but you start doing
more than one you've introduced
complications and that's part of the
reason I put this up is there's limits
limits to the simple parallel axis
theorem but there is a general way of
doing it yes
even why she wish fast so what cause
what what causes these torques when you
have to when you okay we've talked about
this a little bit before the angular
momentum when we calculate angular
momentum does it never involves gravity
it never it gets in there not in the
angular momentum expression so when you
go to compute D the drip time derivative
of the angular momentum you will not
find torques that are caused by gravity
you just can't do them it's not part but
are the torques in the system I mean
when I just hold this here there's mg
down and there's a static moment caused
by this thing trying to twist this down
when you sum the torques when you do the
sum of the torques in them in the
equation you do your Freebody diagram
that term will appear but it is balanced
by some physical torque over here that
balances it does you just won't find it
from doing dhdt it's just part of the
static equilibrium of the system no no
no so she's asking you aski if is
gravity the reason you you I'm not even
quite sure
okay so this let's just say that let's
just make this a real physical problem
I'm making an airplane engine and I'm
making an airplane with propeller on it
and the bearing that supports the
propeller shaft if I put it really close
to the propeller okay then it's doing
this and everything's fine what if I
extended the propeller shaft okay so now
the bearing is back here and now the
propeller spins does that cause any
torques any loads back here on the
bearing because I've extended it no and
you could prove that just by going
through this you do dhdt and you find
out the only torque so when it's nice
and balanced are those required to drive
this propeller in the in the in in the
direction of the axis of rotation but as
soon as you do something to that
propeller like you're mounted off-center
which rarely happens but if you dinged
if you broke off the tip of one of the
blades of this propeller you'd now have
a propeller that looks like that right
and now even in the original system if
you keep it your bearing is right close
this is good this is spinning around but
it is it putting a load sure there's a
centrifugal force that is going by round
around has nothing to do with gravity
nothing at all to do with gravity okay
just just because this is you know the
mass Center is out here it has momentum
the time rate of change of that linear
momentum is ASIS and trip Atal is a
force making this thing go in a circle
okay now if I extend the propeller shaft
so it's like that and I foolishly design
by airplane so it had a long propeller
shaft sticking out there if there's a
little bit of unbalance in this blade so
that you're not spinning about the mass
center you're spinning about some other
point now that centrifugal force going
around is pulling this is bending
and bend this back and forth around this
bearing and because of the way in which
we formulate angular momentum if you
formulated about that point and take its
time derivative you it will reveal those
moments it's really amazing that it can
do that for you but it has a zero
nothing to do with gravity okay all
right so handy hard to remember this
from just a blackboard presentation but
it's in that second reading by Williams
he doesn't not very it proves it in a
very simple way using no summations of
the MIR eyes and so forth proves it in a
very simple way but it's very general
handy formula that you can use okay so
let's have another topic which I'm not
going to do we've got a few minutes you
have muddy cards be in thinking about
that and let's ask questions yeah
where did I get thee I was doing that
kind of fast and I probably even messed
it up so let's let me check thee so I
was doing for the example that our G a
equals we moved it over by a I and up by
ck so n plus 0 J we didn't move it in
the J direction okay so this is my mount
that I've moved that have moved it in an
amount a and amount C so the Williams
formula would say ah that new mass
moment of inertia matrix with respect to
a becomes the original plus and now I
every place there's a B here it goes to
0
and the remaining bits I add with those
so I should get a em whoops this is a C
squared no second term the third term is
minus ma see over here that one is zero
this one becomes a squared plus C
squared - yep M and this one is minus ma
see zero eyes easy and a squared plus B
squared so it's just a squared so that's
this is now correct
pardon ye all of these needs am ma
Squared's em em em em okay so that's our
problem when we did two shifts but a
second we shifted it in two directions
we get these off diagonal terms which
means that if you are actually making
this device rotate about point a you
will get these unbalanced moments it's
dynamically unbalanced okay yeah you
trying to find
why he's asking advice on whether or not
we ought to be trying to find the angle
the inertia matrix about other points
right like yeah i with respect to a
where i started today i said you can
always you can basically do all the
problems with these three equations and
this doesn't mention parallel axis
theorem we use this to find in fact to
solve this problem we didn't talk fair
alaska's theorem at all it just got the
answer dropped out and if we looked into
that care if we could generalize that we
could work now with that a bit and say
oh there's a pattern to this I'll bet
this can be recast like this and it can
so if you want to if you if you know
this exists and you don't want to have
to grind through finding these the terms
that come from here you can do the
problems by finding the mass moment of
inertia matrix with respect to a you can
use this form only when you have fixed
axis rotation the thing is at the point
a is about which this rotation is
occurring then you can write down write
the formula just directly like that so
you've got to be careful when you apply
the parallel axis theorem okay this
brought this the nice thing about these
three forms is to generally true a point
a can move point ay can be accelerating
the problem that we did here point a is
accelerating not only moving it's
actually is that even an inertial frame
we solved this problem this is a non
inertial frame
went right at it and got and solved it
directly okay so I would say if you have
any doubt to answer to your question
when you're in doubt just use the
formula you know need to and then you
will need to find moments of inertia
with respect to the center of mass and
it's in your interest to use principal
axes because they're easier yeah ah so
if you took the derivative of this dhdt
right this one just gives you Omega Z
mega dot mega z dot that's your spin in
the direction of rotation this term that
unit vector rotates this gives you two
terms gives you a I term Omega dot I and
it gives you an Omega
J term okay and what those are those are
two torques this problem there is a
torque caused by the centrifugal force
trying to bend this in the in the J
direction and if this is accelerating
you know beta double dot term there is a
torque trying to bend this thing
backwards okay get them both all right
muddy cards and see you on Thursday
Thursday we're going to do a nasty
problem and it is that lead-in to a
problem you can do the same problem
extraordinary easily using energy and
that's kind of the purpose of doing it
so you see both ways of doing it